how are you i'm all right how you doing
i'm i'm doing great uh let me start with
congratulations on the movie i am sure
it's been a very tough day to do press
with everyone coming in saying positive
things
oh right
yeah i've been on the other side of that
where people didn't really have anything
to say at all so
this has been this has been pleasurable
uh the first thing i need to say is uh
how disappointed i am that um hbo did
not say yes to a season two of lovecraft
oh me too
i was really
really bummed about that and just want
to say great work on the first season
thank you thank you thank you jumping
into why i actually get to talk to you
if someone if someone had made this
written this as a script and said you
know in hollywood like this is what i
believe that can happen everyone would
have laughed them out out of the room
like it's so preposterous the story when
you actually started researching and
getting ready for this thing what were
some of the things that you thought were
this has to be made up but it's actually
true they had daughters
with the intention of making them tennis
stars
and that sounds crazy
but that's what happened
that's what happened um
and then beyond that
they wanted them to be tennis stars but
when they had when they were in the
world and they saw how incredible they
incredible that they were
that
mr williams was so insistent on them
being young ladies and girls before they
were tennis players
and hit it looked like he was
you know what maniacal right
but in fact there was he was being he
was being a genius and he would
you know sort of do these things that
looked you know
that looked nonsensical and irrational
but there was there was it was all a
part of his plan
for his daughters so obviously will will
is what we call a talented actor he's
kind of good you know most people i'm
obviously underselling but um what was
it like actually working with him
like day in and day out what did you
take away from the experience that maybe
surprised you about you know will that
maybe you didn't expect going in well i
didn't i didn't come into it with any
sort of presumptions about him
but what i what i know is is that um
he doesn't have to do what he what he's
doing now he doesn't have to do it the
way that he does it now but he
he is he when i first walked into
rehearsal the first day
he had posted notes on the window
of every beat of every scene
and
he would we would go through those go
through those notes meticulously until
we figured out this story
and i have i
that's that kind of dedication and
devotion to specificity and detail
was to me the the hallmark of someone
who just started right you know what i
mean but he has been doing it so long
and and and doing it so well for so long
it is still as important to him to get
it right
and that's so it's just so wonderful to
witness
someone work that way and also beyond
that he took care of everybody he would
not allow anybody to be mistreated in
his presence he was constantly speaking
up for people
constantly trying to make people feel
welcome
and taken care of in scene work and just
on set in general
and when you're in the presence of that
you perform better i i already have to
stop i'm just gonna say seriously again
congrats on the movie you guys did such
great work i i know people are gonna
love it for sure thank you so much thank
you for watching it oh please
this is one of those it's like oh yeah
i'm it's you know what i mean we both
know
it's a good one
gonna they're gonna throw me out um good
luck with the rest of your interviews
okay thank you so much